if women are allowed to have height
filters
why um on dating apps why can't men have
weight filters he says they call him you
said they can't they don't
oh i don't see a quote i don't see him i
know you don't see a problem you don't
see a problem no i don't see a problem
okay i also don't see a problem what you
like what you like yeah you like what
you like yeah yeah what was your
preference whether you're brave enough
to present what you like to actually
like yes
what do you mean brave enough to present
people are just scared to
beat them say yeah to say oh i like a
bigger girl or
i like like slim like really slim
because more times like what teagan is
saying people actually just go for
not all the time i mean correct myself
but majority of the time people actually
go for people that are slim or
hourglass big booty kim k type body
so
i don't i just think it's preference
yeah well that's probably the most in
demand is the hourglass body yeah like
that's probably just what they like the
most like
you know i think girls like what six
four guys the most
six four six four five
two six
six two i think on dating apps it's six
four is like the primary my neck is
gonna be doing up elastic girl
yeah it's kind of it's kind of weird
because some girls are like
five foot with a six foot four mm-hmm
yeah
so i don't know it just depends
so the one question i have is
do you guys think
women will say that we want a guy and
not you guys particular but i hear this
often from women six foot six six inches
six figures have you heard that before
yes yes
yeah
what is that so
but at the
they shame men for what they want so
they'll they'll call them fat phobic or
the new one is ageist what is that ages
ages so so they say that they say that
men discriminate against overweight
women and old women
but when a woman has a standard we don't
go up to the women and say oh you're
discriminating against broke men and
short men
i would but i don't think i represent
all women so you would do what which i
would tell them that's not that's not
fair i i think there's such a double
standard in society when it comes to oh
absolutely
you'll say it's not fair to date a broke
man like like that you shouldn't
disagree yeah oh i think you should
why would you want to date a guy that's
going nowhere in life not broke
like if a guy if a guy can't hold a job
i think they're trying to be very nice
to be fair as well i do think i am
actually too nice okay i have something
i might need
don't make that mistake again because
honestly i would not tell you as a man
yeah if you're preference let's say
someone that's tall go for a tall guy if
your preference is someone that is has
six figures and you can get that go get
that
but if like
if you're gonna try and convince me that
money occupation status in life in a man
is not something that you're concerned
with
just come on don't lie now do you know
what i'm saying
i'll be honest with you money is not a
big thing for me
i understand if you're not materialistic
23. yes that's typical women
no women it tends to switch where money
becomes more important around like 26.
and that makes sense as well because men
don't really peak until they're like in
their 30s yeah yeah money you might not
care now but when you're picking a guy
that you may have kids with and you'd
have to rely on him for a couple years
while you raise the kids um it becomes
more important
fair enough but i mean obviously i'm
young in it but at my age i don't even
see kids in my future so i think that's
also why
i prioritize money less yeah i wouldn't
do you think that is might change with
age as well potentially i feel like
so there was this guy i was talking to
he
was unemployed
and
he was just selling drugs to get by
you are too pretty to be deal no i'm
serious you can get a guy with a job
you're very pretty
oh come on girl you had to have had guys
with real jobs interested i don't
believe like i do not believe for a
second you you're 23 you're in shape
you're attractive you're you're nice to
be around you're telling me a drug
dealer that was why why would you pick
him
i didn't
pick him
i met him and i was like see a smooth
talk he had ambition i was like i'm not
gonna knock anyone cuz i'm unemployed
right now i don't have a job i'm
basically broke i'm living at home so
he's more ambitious than you
he's making that money for the drug deal
but i don't know his ambition
i don't get it did he at least have good
customer service he's a good drug dealer
i mean i don't i didn't get anything off
him he wasn't my drug dealer i don't do
drugs yeah
i was like you know what i'll give him
the benefit of the doubt and i was like
at least he's not living at home not
trying to get a job he was trying to get
a job he was a plan he could have been
lying to me
but i believed him when he said he was
trying to get a job so i was like i'm
not going to say no
just because
i wouldn't automatically label you a
slacker just because you're a drug
dealer
is this a guy that put you in the friend
zone no okay does he want to date you
i don't chat to him anymore oh okay did
you end it with him yeah
i'm glad
[Laughter]
but yeah i mean i'm probably not the
best person to ask because i am quite
inexperienced but just at least from my
point of view now at my age
money is not a big thing for me and i
think maybe with my career as well
personally i find it's quite hard to
make money through dance i'm not doing
it for the money i'm doing it because i
enjoy it i don't want to work nine to
five in an office that's just not me i
like to do site creative
and i feel like dance is underfunded
people don't really want to pay dancers
they want us to work for free
we just do it for the exposure so um
yeah so for me yeah money's not the
motive
would i like a guy that had money yeah
but it's not the main for me
but if if there's two guys in front of
you
and one was making six figures and one
wasn't you'd pick the guy that makes six
figures am i right or wrong it depends
on what the other guy's doing if the
other guy's doing something creative
i'll go for him he'd rather go for the
creative guy that makes less money yes
okay
i feel like in all of the conversations
that we've had we haven't actually
spoken about feelings because feelings
are a big part of relationships yeah
right
no okay not important no
i don't think i don't think your
feelings are important if when selecting
a long-term partner
it doesn't it doesn't because feelings
come and go
like that's why i think a lot of modern
women are selfish because they'll leave
a marriage because of their feelings
your feelings are they're expected to
come and go
so like when when i'm looking for
someone like long-term you want someone
that has character
and
i mean you're attracted to but
do i think like my feelings are that
important and picking someone to marry
and like build a family with
sometimes in marriage for if you're
going to marry a guy so so i'm 25. let's
say i get married at 30 okay and let's
say i live to be 80. that's that's 50
years
so i think at some point i probably
won't like him that much but it's about
like duty and commitment
but
like a lot of modern women it's about
it's about like how we feel in the
moment instead of like
what
is the best choice for us long term and
we can even see this with you i mean a
drug deal i mean come on
that was a mistake okay i've dated guys
i should have been like i'm not i'm not
perfect but i think as women like
historically a lot of times men made
decisions for us when it comes to dating
and i think there's a reason for that
because
a lot of times we pick wrong because we
rely on our feelings well can i add to
that because it's it's interesting to me
uh
coming from a muslim background
dating is just
it's considered forbidden in in islam
the reason for that being is that
let's say if i'm dating a woman i'm not
giving her any commitment i could just
take advantage of her sexually and then
move on
right there's no kind of commitment
there she might get heartbroken
emotionally troubled all sorts of things
um
but
in islam what you're supposed to do is
just courtship i think you're supposed
to get to know
whoever but families are involved from
the get-go you're supposed to vet the
partner that you're with do you know
what i mean you can't just go in there
blind thinking okay i'm gonna just
figure this out day to day go speak to
their family members let them speak to
yours engage in that way so that you can
really understand what this kind what
this person that you want to be your
partner is all about
if you're going to go in there dating oh
yeah you know let's have some fun let's
go to the theater let's go do this let's
go do that
that's fine but
it doesn't
uh reveal to you whether you guys would
be good
partners long term whether you guys
would be able to take care of children
whether in the stressful days you guys
are going to not tear each other's heads
off and all this kind of stuff because
that's when it's all rosy the first
couple of years of dating
but dating i think is just a it's an
illusion you either are gunning towards
commitment
or you're just playing pretend you're in
a in a situation with someone and it's
not really truthfully going to go
anywhere
if you aren't discussing commitment from
the get-go in my opinion anyway
like what's what's the point what is the
point of dating if there's not
commitment down the line in the
future it doesn't make sense to me like
dating in general just dating aimlessly
as well what do you guys think about
that
i would agree yeah i get that but but i
also feel like that is but sometimes
i'll deal well
and i feel like it's not an ideal world
and i feel like well for me personally i
would
in an ideal world i would like to be
friends with someone for a long time so
i can get to know them what they're like
on a friendship level obviously not the
same as being in a relationship then i
get to know what they're liking hard
situations good situations and then if
there's a vibe
it moves on or for me i would rather if
it was a date and situation i would get
to know them over a long period of time
hold back on sex hold back on certain
things but i just feel like for me so
many guys don't want to wait yeah so
it's just really hard
it's really hard or they want they want
sex
to then give you the commitment that you
want basically
yeah that's backwards i don't agree
that's what i'm saying
it's but a lot of times i don't think
girls have the conversations up front i
mean it depends what you want do you
like if you want a boyfriend if you want
to be married but i think a lot of times
having the conversation up front about
like where this is going is is helpful
and also involving like like i don't
know um i know some of you said that you
don't have fathers to help you with this
but i always involve my dad i like tell
them about the guys i'm dating and it's
really helpful because men can kind of
see through like other guys [ __ ] a
lot faster than you
so if i'm if i'm like seeing a guy or
i'm going on dates with him and i like
tell my dad like stuff he's saying or
whatever like my dad will tell me yes or
no and i try to listen to him and he's
always right what were you going to say
you said about feelings you said it's
not an ideal
go ahead
well i just
i don't even know where i'm going with
this but
in a long-term relationship as much as
like you have duties and you have
like
them hard situations obviously
but
there needs to be some sort of
connection to want to stay with that
person
sure for that amount of time speaking
for that amount of time don't you think
of course well this one has to be oh
yeah i mean you have to get along in
order to get to the point yeah
but you guys are saying how feeling
comes and goes like are you not gonna i
think they may have that feeling i think
i think guys i think i think they mean
like so in like in a certain situation
sound like you're married obviously and
like
i don't know like if something's if
something is happening not in the
relationship but if something is just
happening in general sometimes you just
gotta put your feelings in the side and
deal with that situation i think that's
what they i think that's no no
what i understand by
feeling should not be the judgment of
how you pick your relationships is the
fact that if you feel something towards
someone at a mo that moment right that
person could be for example broke a drug
dealer doing whatever he wants to be
doing right and you're going oh my gosh
i love him i feel my feelings are
telling me i want to be with him you
will make a bad decision that will have
long-term consequences which is why we
say feelings should not be the biggest
or the most relevant point of why you
are in a relationship they shouldn't
dictate a relationship it should be
things like status it should be job it
should be character right all of these
things are the focus of what will be
good or conducive for a long-term
relationship if you're picking based on
feelings lord knows lord knows you're
not going to have a great time
but feeling that how like you have to
take that into account in
the the
in a small capacity yes yeah that's what
i would i would say it's secondary
like i would say characters above all
else
but in height i'm sorry shortcuts
don't worry
out here you're in a long-term
relationship and you went for this
person because of his status because of
whatever whatever but you're in the
worst relationship and
you're married to this person or you
don't have to stay but you've chosen
this person because of
what they do or what they do then you'll
have kids which you'll find your joy
through
well if you don't want it yeah okay so
those are other obstacles that you you
may face like if you don't want kids
then that's something that's your own
choice like there will be
in the long term you'll find that there
will be so many things that you would
have avoided
because you chose
based on the factors that were important
as opposed to using your feelings you'll
find that
a lot of relationships that you may have
been in previously may have not
been great or may have not gone well due
to you picking
based on your feelings yeah and i can i
can even say first hand like i've picked
guys that i like i shouldn't have picked
because like you know of of my feelings
but i've just learned that like
character is the most important thing
especially when choosing a husband